fana welcome back to St Louis your home
uh welcome back to gr how do you feel to
come back here after Grand Swiss it's
just one week ago the tournament has
finished how did you assess your result
yeah it was it's good to be back I I
right before Grand Swiss I was playing
an event here the US Chess Championship
and I I had this event in between which
was a very very big and influential
event for a lot of players and for me
there was a little bit less writing on
it because I wasn't trying to qualify
for the candidate
um but it was a very exciting event
anyway and uh decided two places in the
candidates tournament so that was that
was very important vid and Nakamura made
their um had their success there and
yeah for me it was a little bit less um
of an exciting event let's say it was
going quite decently and then at the end
I kind of ran out of steam and the
Finish was very disappointing for me uh
so overall it wasn't like very negative
or very positive certainly a little bit
disappointing but I'm hoping that
what I'm looking forward to is that we
have rapid and Blitz now so it's a bit
of a change because I played in the last
uh few months mostly classical chess I
had how many games you played I
wonder like we played 11 in the US
Championship quite a long and tough
event and then 11 in the grand Swiss so
a little bit longer than average and
here we have in the singfield cup nine
classical games a little bit of a more
usual uh schedule but it's nice that we
have a kind of intereso before so we
have rapid and blit just a little bit
let's say less pressure in terms of
preparation and and that sort of thing
and more based on like your current form
and how you're feeling your mood so I'm
hoping that I'll be in good shape for
that also for me it's very important of
course um because I'm In Contention in
the grand chest tour standings I'm in a
good position but last two events will
be very critical yeah for sure and
coming back a little bit to this the
candidates tournament and your sport
there I mean you you said that you
played in Grand Swiss with a strange
feeling yes that you were you already
qualified you reached your goal already
and how was it actually to play there I
mean having in mind that let's say you
don't need to to do so and what do you
think about the other players how
difficult it was for them yeah I can say
from experience that these events are a
lot of pressure and even this year when
I was playing the World Cup it was a
huge amount of pressure and I felt it
very strongly physical effects the
tiredness and everything and the grand
swis was a bit different because I
didn't really feel that pressure but I'm
not sure maybe it wasn't a good thing
like maybe it's better to feel that
drive to like you have to win this game
I I remember in The Grand in 2021 it was
I I had to qualify for the candidates
via that tournament and I was playing
Ali Resa in penultimate round no sorry
two rounds before the end and I kind of
felt like I really need to win this game
and I was able to win it and to secure
cada's qualification mostly because of
that win against Ali Resa and this time
I think if I needed to qualify I would
consider the game against deak in two
rounds before the end again like
absolute must- win to get top two like
very very important to win this game and
I didn't have this feeling of like
intensity so maybe it also um sort of
let me down in a way in that sense while
during the World Cup I had a really
strong feeling of like intensity like
every game is super crucial so it gave
me a lot of stress I I wouldn't say it's
like good for my health but maybe it's
good for tournament performance yeah
like for example Nakamura had to try to
win against you right in order to get
the spot in the candidates and speaking
about this tournament I mean how often
do you think about you know it's going
to be on April there are so many events
in between and things to do but still do
you think about the event and what do
you think about the field which we know
already the candidates the candidates
yes let's say yeah know I for me it's
the biggest event on the calendar for
sure like every event is important every
event I care about but um there's only
one two events a year that I really like
um put all my effort into preparation
before the tournament and everything
like coming to singfield cup I mostly
have a normal schedule
and for candidates of course everyone is
is taking it so seriously because it's a
unique chance to play a world
championship match that and almost
always first place is the only one which
counts yeah last time was a bit unusual
that second place ended up also counting
but usually you really need to win so of
course you need some luck in order like
you need the right circumstances but you
also need um very good preparation and
you need to be on form so everyone takes
it the most seriously that they can
and I I've played many already uh so I
have a lot of experience but I sometimes
I wonder if this experience is like
super important or not because the first
time I played in 2016 I had no
experience and my preparation wasn't
ideal let's say looking back on it but
somehow I almost qualif almost almost
was able to to pull it off and Sergey
kaken was the one who who qualified for
a world championship match that time so
sometimes I don't know if it's more like
experience or um sometimes coming into
it for the first time like we'll see
some players in next one um is also like
a huge motivation like prag nanta is the
first time I think um also
abasov I know he's not 100% in but uh
but assuming he plays then it's also
first time for him and vidit as well so
we see a few first timers here I think
it's it's both the most interesting
event of the Year besides the world
championship match but also um for the
players of course takes on a unique
amount of stress and uh pressure yes so
this what I wish you I mean all the best
of luck in this in this tournament thank
you thank you thanks